There is of course,
great interest in and potential for genomics research.
Earlier, we mentioned personalized or precision medicine as a major goal for health care.
While social, environmental and other factors
clearly affect the development and course of disease,
genomic variations are a major determinant
of each person's health and response to treatments.
There are at least two major challenges that informatics,
supplied to large genomic data sets can help solve.
Many genomic variations are rare,
so aggregating data from multiple centers is important.
It's often necessary to correlate these variations with clinical data,
to understand their ramifications.
It's worth repeating that last point.
We do not yet understand the ramifications of most genomic variations.
By linking clinical data where the phenotypic expression
of genomic variations is stored with the genomic data,
the hope is that we can understand these relationships.
Genomic research networks may overcome these challenges.
For example, three major pediatric health systems
recently formed the Genomics Research and Innovation Network, GRIN.
Because each alone may have only a handful of patients with a particular rare disease,
to help better understand the clinical ramifications of gene variations,
GRIN seeks to create a broad database of annotated genomic and clinical data.
It will add RNA proteomics and
metabolomic data to an existing shared library of genomic sequencing data.
The network also wants to connect
the genomic data with imaging results and electronic health records.
The initial focus is on early childhood obesity,
growth disorders, short stature, and epilepsy.
The epilepsy project explores epileptic encephalopathy,
a process where epileptic activity impairs overall brain function,
including cognitive function, language and behavior.
As you can see here,
in data from online mundanely inheritance in man holmium,
a number of genes may have an association with this condition.
Once exome sequencing is completed,
the data is to be stored in a joint shared cloud environment,
combined with extracted phenotypic data from
the electronic medical records of the three centers,
in an effort to better elucidate and understand these relationships.